[Musique]
au moins chez les républicains un thème
fait consensus c'est l'immigration
d'immigration l'immigration
l'immigration aujourd'hui une
immigration incontrôlée le mono maniaque
sur les questions d'immigration non je
vais y revenant excusez moi c'est juste
maniacs et bfm tv
pardon
de dénoncer un jour d'un jeu balance
mais
je propose de baisser de 30%
l'immigration du travail réduire de
moitié l'immigration des étudiants qui
viennent en france divisée par 3
l'immigration familiale michel barnier
explicite son moratoire sur
l'immigration pourquoi un moratoire
parce qu'il faut donner un coup d'arrêt
immédiat à certain nombre de flux et
même à tous les flux comme monsieur
barnier ird il ya des régions entières
on sent plus français des régions
entières excessif faut l'avouer bon ben
voilà c'est électorale a été
radicalisé et dont les dirigeants et
leurs noms n'ont pas amené à comprendre
que le monde était complexe ils votent
pour monsieur zemmour ou pas même le pen
chez les responsables qui ont parlé hier
il ya un effet zemmour ils font la
course à l'échalote le concours lépine
et encore le préfet lépine n'a pas être
mêlé à ça de l'idée la plus radicale
possible françois fillon son épouse et
son ex suppléant jugé en appel à partir
d'aujourd'hui dans la sphère des
soupçons d'emplois fictifs de pénélope
fillon comme assistante parlementaire il
y a des yeux qui sont des lieux de
souffrance qui sont des lieux de martyrs
ce ne sont pas des lieux de polémique
c'est aussi simple que vous n'auriez pas
fait sur le fond il ya un an et demi
françois fillon avait été condamné à
cinq ans d'emprisonnement dont deux
ferme 375 mille euros d'amendé et dix
ans d'inéligibilité
checkpoint à certains endroits à
schaffen ça rappelle la palestine israël
faut pas être mieux des barragistes non
mais des barrages est excessif de ses
parents non genre accessible mais je
réalise cheval fm je pense que je vois
plus ces policiers me semble-t-il que je
suis plus de nuit avec eux que vous ne
peut enfermer ce qui est vrai rencontre
un certain sur cette image le drapeau
tricolore est hantée d'un bleu cobalt
c'était il y a deux ans mais aujourd'hui
une du ans plus foncée flotte au dessus
de l'élise et le bleu marine on les vire
d'abord la différence est visible entre
ces deux prises de parole du chef de
l'état giscard avait changé le bleu pour
des questions esthétiques lors du
rapprochement avec l'europe mais le
drapeau que tous les présidents se
traînait depuis n'était pas le vrai
drapeau français alors j'ai vérifié
effectivement 76 valery giscard guiscard
des spas éclaircie un petit peu ce
drapeau fut en autriche ce nouveau tour
de vis inédit depuis la crise sanitaire
les personnes non vaccinées devront
rester confiné oui cela représente près
de 2 millions d'individus
les patrouilles vont être renforcées et
gare aux infractions les amendes sont
comprises elles entre 500 et 1500 euros
si le gouvernement en arrive là c'est
que le pays a battu un record de cas ce
week end treize mille nouvelles
infections et la france n'est pas à
l'abri d'une nouvelle vague donc il nous
faut à l'abri confinement
l'objectif est la méthode que nous avons
eue c'est celle de la vaccination est
celle du rappel le président a depuis
que l'a rappelé la semaine dernière tout
faire pour éviter un nouveau confinement
tout fait rire parce que ça n'est pas
bon pour nous ce n'est pas bon pour nos
vies privées ce n'est pas bon pour la
société ce n'est pas bon pour le moral
de mes enfants ça n'est pas bon pour
notre économie l'hypothèse d'un
confinement était encore sur la table
mais toutes les hypothèses sont sur la
table parce que nous sommes face à un
virus qui nous surprend et peut encore
nous surprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou contournent l'interdiction de cette
obligation vaccinale par l'intermédiaire
d'un pass sanitaire que l'on rend de
plus en plus coercitif
[Musique]